il m'a traité mois des paf qu'est-ce que
tu l'as dit je m'en fous je lui ai dit
tu étais pas totalement une merde
kruger a raison je suis tu n'es pas ça
lui va bien de dire ça a cru que tu vas
pas recommencer clair est-ce que je dois
te rappeler l'unité c'est disent ils en
faisaient pas partie pendant l'apartheid
c'est kruger qui m'a fait nommer
capitaine c'est super mais combien de
noirs il a tué et torturé avec la place
me dis pas qu'il faisait pas partie de
ces salles on a décidé qu'on serait
capable de vivre tous ensemble
le passé c'est le passé donc est-ce
qu'on peut jouer aux cartes kruger était
amnistié pardonnait sûr qu'on l'a
amnistié kruger et tous ces assassins et
tous ces voleurs c'est trop facile on
passe devant une commission de fantoches
on a vous tous les crimes qu'on a commis
et boom tout est pardonné en un clin
d'oeil une absolution instantané c'est
tout moi ça serait un peu tu crois pas
on a été trop gentils avec ses fils de
[ __ ] non ils s'en sont bien tirés
libre comme des [ __ ] d'oiseaux plus
riche que jamais comme si s'était rien
passé
mais qu'est ce que tu aurais préféré des
représailles encore des morts non ali
pas des représailles la justice j'aurais
préféré la justice clair s'il ya bien
quelqu'un ses tables qui pourraient
avoir des raisons de se venger c'est ali
mais il se trouve qu'il a le courage et
l'intelligence de pardonner si tu veux
faire la paix avec ton ennemi alors tu
travailles avec ton ennemi et il devient
ton partenaire mandela
alors voulu cacher ses cartes ou quoi et
on cache les gars et les filles